i was taking 40 milligrams of adderall
just to wake up in the morning i was
taking dapzone which is an antibiotic
used to treat leprosy so that my skin
would heal i was taking 40 milligrams of
ecetalopram for the depression i was
taking an inhaler because if i got a
cold it would turn into bronchitis that
would turn into pneumonia night out in
the hospital because of the immune
suppressants i was taking a prescription
strength antihistamine because i was so
allergic to trees and grass that i was
verging on anaphylaxis in the spring i
cut everything out
except for beef thinking i'm nuts and
hopefully i don't get vitamin
deficiencies the itch went away and my
joints started to feel better four weeks
after that so six weeks after an all
beef diet the depression lifted and i
stopped crying in the morning and five
months after that the anxiety lifted and
i was back in what i felt was heaven
compared to how i'd been living i've
been talking about this diet to spread
awareness in hopes that the medical
community can take something like this
seriously i've talked to thousands of
people with autoimmune disorders who've
done similar things and seen similar
results